night vision why you are sitting on the
bench looking like your name Dolores
hold me Ruth
give it here put this on put this on
member those missing packages yeah the
kids the corner stores stolen boxes what
about it turns out people at my job at
tipping off the thieves I'm with the
steal and that's why you out here
looking like Madea I gave him a fake
address and an empty box and a sent to
this location now we just wait oh I like
stakeouts okay do this
so how long we suppose somebody shoots
up I need complete silence man cool Shh
hey yo y'all fellas love hip-hop there
you go baby
oh god is dead long live me gotta get
that new hot mixtape right there very my
old lady undercover old ladies need
impromptu look right look at you oh man
I know that bullet hole hoodie from
anywhere is Brandon my kids love you
don't always support the Arts there you
go brother I'm gonna hit right that is
ten note Kenda is 1010 now hey there we
go hey all right
support you the heroes respect you here
what about you you're grumpy ed sir
nobody listens to CDs anymore do you
have a soundcloud or something monster
grandbaby hey be nice to this man he's a
citizen a citizen
this guy's a dinosaur the fact that he
thinks I have a place I can play a CD
shows me he's not up with the times
which also shows me he hasn't read and
if he doesn't read that means his rhymes
have no content it has rhymes has no
content it means his rising talking
about and you'll never make it as a
rapper you need a freestyle yeah you got
a beat up in the beat I don't have a
beat me in my home with me in the crib
and we get your drop drippity drip drip
of the drop and the pops
[Music]
hey mommy you have to go to Steel's box
oh thank you we are gentrify ginger
who wait for me you know the superhero
interrogations I'll show you how to do
it who is this ah I wanna go
can you stop killing people before we
get the information he was cooperating
the fourth one this week that's my bad
my grip I'm trying to work on it ginger
five chunks your eyes I knew this wasn't
random man he's package things woman in
the face you just steer to get be a bad
girl wait a minute you sexist okay let
me can do things just as well as me just
wrong I agree thank you
[Music]
bell rings out the kitchen is a very
intelligent smart animal night bitch
hey Ms lady you like hip-hop I got I
guess not
[Music]
hello gentrify mr. age we got a problem
you